foreign
to the train because I had such a
terrible experience in my high school
years and saw so many friends dead
suicide drug addicts in jail like
wrecked their lives I had so many
challenges taking myself from
essentially a loser with nowhere to go
to you know a trajectory within Academia
and taking good care of my body that I
was like no drugs no drugs I don't even
put psyched dogs in the category of
drugs and here I'm lumping MDMA and
they're provided it's done with
a licensed physician or clinician who
can guide this stuff it's been immensely
beneficial for me what were your
different sessions like
to the extent that you're willing to
share the first one I can just summarize
by saying was extremely somatic
waves of a lot of shaking
at the beginning of the session I walked
in feeling like I could think and feel
things from the neck up I could think
and feel things not think but I could
feel things from the waist down but that
my body wasn't integrated as a system I
left that session feeling completely
comfortable in my body as a whole system
and Far More in tune with my emotions
far more comfortable being having
emotions far less afraid of what
emotions might do to me whether or not
they were a vote from inside or from
outside I felt as a consequence I felt
much braver in the world
and I felt a kind of a healthy adaptive
level of fearlessness because I felt
like nothing can hijack my internal
emotions and even if they do I'll be
okay
and that was a significant thing the
second session very different I expected
everything as I did in the first it
never works that way was one of deep
deep
acceptance around
resents forgiveness of resents that I
had for people that I felt had neglected
me or just or did not do what they
needed to do or that I felt a lot of and
you might be able to sense a little bit
of emotion here it's it's hard because I
can still sense the ways in which
thoughts about that are painful but
mostly because it's it seems so
senseless to me now yeah and yet I have
truly zero resent like I I look for it
often to just check myself to it no
resent like complete forgiveness which
has given me tremendous relief
and then the third session was
interesting third session was a higher
dose I had never taken the booster the
maps booster took the booster and
I lay completely still for about eight
hours and it was very introspective and
I think I left that session and I still
maintained from all the everything I've
described by the way I feel I've
maintained years later now
the third session which was more recent
I felt I finally understood
and kind of sealed up what I can only
describe as like boundaries like that
other people can have emotions and
experiences that are truly separate from
me I tend to be pretty affiliative I
think that came out of an early
especially with friends you know and in
relationships that came out of an early
need to
feel some sense of family where I didn't
feel that as much as I would have liked
from my biological family
and there have been times when I've been
unable to really
keep in touch with kind of how my my
life and and is distinct from and my
emotions are distinct from other people
a little bit too much of empathic
blurring sometimes and I felt like that
was just sealed right up
and mind you each time I went into these
sessions I was afraid of all the
standard things losing my mind having a
heart attack now granted if you have
heart issues tell your physician you
don't want to do MDMA it is an
amphetamine in there yeah but I was
afraid of all the standard stuff each
time I felt like the window on
introspection and plasticity lasted much
longer weeks longer and
each time I just felt like I got better
and better at self-care which in my mind
was always a very selfish thing yeah I
always thought self-care is selfish you
know even working out I used to hide
working out when I'd go to conferences
because I thought like no academic like
goes to the gym and lifts weights and I
really like doing that but I realized
how much stronger I was mentally when I
was taking care of my physical body but
I think that things have changed now but
so the third session was very meaningful
for me because I felt like it kind of
sealed something up yeah where I go okay
like I'm I'm good like things can happen
around me and I'm not gonna get pulled
into it
in a way that compromises my well-being
yeah of course I still have a lot in
there and work to do and Robin cardard
Harris
said to me recently he said well you
know psilocybin is really the honest
psychedelic because there you don't have
the empathogen that's woven into the
MDMA so you're really gonna see whatever
Darkness still exists within you and I
thought oh goodness but you know spoken
as a true psilocybin research you know
so so they hear they you know you hear
about people like is it calling to you
I'm afraid to do psilocybin for that
reason I definitely worked hard to kind
of suppress some of the dark clouds in
my head
and yeah but the fact that I'm still a
bit afraid for them is probably the
reason why I should do it
oh I also I think means you're coming to
it from an intellectually honest place
if if someone has absolutely no concerns
or misgivings about
extremely powerful psychedelics
I mean you are playing with
psychological nuclear power so yeah
revealing the unconscious I mean I
didn't even know what psychedelic meant
but it I mean Robin taught me it means
revealing the unconsciousness yeah mind
manifesting yeah and I still do you know
extensive amounts of psychotherapy and
psycho analysis I look at that as just
like going to the gym yeah I'm fortunate
that my insurance can help pay for that
and I'm able to pay for it so I
understand not everybody can but I I
still feel that
yeah if we don't actually take the time
to figure out what's going on in our
head so how can we really trust that
we're on the best path yeah or just
representing
reality to our benefit in a sense right
because we're we're perceiving but also
constructing reality and sometimes
if you think your glasses are scratched
or smeared or foggy or whatever you need
to take them off and look at them there
are a few ways to do that with your own
psyche there are very few tools that
allow you to do that and I would
recommend for folks if they are
interested in and thank you for being so
forthcoming with describing your
experiences
getting a good overview of how
MDMA specifically can help with say
complex PTSD and why it has become such
a focal point for many many researchers
and practitioners I do recommend the
Netflix how to change your mind
miniseries that pollen was involved with
based on the book of the same name and
specifically the the MDMA episode I
thought was was spectacularly well done
I need to see that still it's very well
done and includes a lot of case studies
and interviews with research subjects
and there's also documentary that I
helped bring to well outside of Israel
called trip of compassion this was
probably four or five years ago which
contains session footage as well
production value is going to be a bit
lower than Netflix so you might want to
try that first but their number of
forthcoming books coming that'll be that
will be focused on these topics a lot of
good stuff happening it's exciting